he walks down the runway wearing a
plastic bag before a security guard
stops him the reason it's going viral is
not because of the the guy this was a
good prank he pulled it off well it's
because the audience looks completely
non-plussed
so yeah there it is there's High fashion
we've all seen this happen before where
some Modern artists will show something
that's not beautiful that's not
particularly intricate that a
three-year-old could have put together
in two seconds and because of the I
don't know the pretensions of the artist
and of our culture you'll have otherwise
serious you know well-dressed wealthy
Elite people looking at it trying to
pretend as though there's some deeper
meaning or that it's in some way
aesthetically pleasing